Here's another case study.
I simply put two pieces
of paper overlapping.
These papers are used for
particular medical analysis.
So I captured it, once again,
at a very high resolution,
so that as we zoom
into the image,
we can actually see the
fibers in the paper.
Here's an image where I
added background color.
Now, I'm not changing
the important information
in the image-- the structure.
The structure is the data.
I'm just adding an
additional component
to allow the viewer to
see the material better.
We'll be looking at adding
backgrounds in the how to do it
section.
I want to spend a few
minutes on backgrounds.
I am a bit of a
background collector.
And, frankly, I think
you should be one, too.
Really, it helps a lot
to imagine your images,
even while you're not
even working on it.
Whenever some interesting
envelope or card
arrives in my mailbox, I
keep it, believe it or not,
thinking that it might
help with an image one day.
Or platters.
Or wired thingies.
Anything that might be
appropriate for a background
for small devices.
And besides, it's
fun to think about.
So let's take a look
at one particular idea.
Take this simple graph paper,
which I tried as a background
for this device.
Looks OK.
Here I tried some bubble
wrap, of all things.
Definitely over the top,
and doesn't work quite well.
There should be some sort of
intelligent visual connection
between your device
and your background,
and bubble wrap
doesn't quite cut it.
In the end I finally landed
on using simple green paper
with this device.
And because the
image was captured
with the scanner sitting
at a high resolution--
it was about a 400-meg file--
I was able to zoom in, crop,
and finalize the image.
I think that both the
simple colored background
and the composition works.
Here we see three
microfluidic devices,
which I initially lined
up in a pretty boring way,
as you see here.
And once again, I'm always
playing with composition,
so what I did was I used
two of them instead.
Just the two of
them really visually
say what you need to say.
We don't need three.
You might think about
that in your own work.
So I captured it at a
very high resolution,
putting the devices
on an angle--
a much more interesting
composition.
And because of the
high resolution,
I was able to zoom in
and crop the image.
Now, watch what happens when
I enhance the image using
a sharpening tool.
We'll talk about sharpening
images in the how to do it
section.
This is an important technique.
The sharpening filter is
not changing your data.
If your data is about
form and structure,
it's permitting you
and your viewers
to see the image clearly.
But whenever any of
these filters are used,
it's imperative
to always indicate
the process in the caption.
Something that I
encourage you to consider.
Because I captured this
at such a high resolution,
we can zoom in and see
30-micron structure.
Here is again.
First, the original image.
And here it is sharpened, where
you can really see the detail.
It's pretty neat.
So this is our first week,
imaging with a flatbed scanner.
Think about it.
It's not an expensive
piece of equipment,
and if used properly, you can
achieve high-quality images
without spending an
inordinate amount of time.
In the next weeks, we'll
talk about cameras,
lenses, lighting, approaches
to imaging science
and engineering.
We'll also discuss
how to graphically use
these images for figures
and potential cover designs.
So lots more ahead, and
I look forward to it.